it was a story straight out of a spy
novel a mysterious weapon used by
hostile agents to target u.s diplomats
around the world a previously unknown
technology in the hands of the enemies
of the free world and it even has a name
straight from the thriller section
the havana syndrome
back in 2016 u.s staff of the american
embassy in cuba started complaining of
severe headaches nausea and other
symptoms after hearing high pitched
sounds sound an official report backed
up reports of brain damage possibly
caused by a sonic weapon the syndrome
has been reported from various locations
across the globe since then
this has become a political issue as
well politicians have pointed their
finger at russia as possibly being
behind the attacks christopher miller
the former acting defense secretary
under donald trump called the suspected
directed energy attacks and quote act of
war but now in the latest twist in this
saga a large-scale cia report into the
havana syndrome reportedly says that
those suffering from the condition were
not targeted in a global campaign by a
foreign power in fact it concludes that
the vast majority of cases were the
result of stress or other conventional
medical explanations
when this story first broke many
scientists warned that the most likely
explanation was mass psychogenic illness
or what is commonly known as mass
hysteria
two of them wrote this book together
havana syndrome mass psychogenic illness
and the real story behind the embassy
mystery and hysteria
and tonight i've got both of those
authors with me i'd like to welcome
robert w balo he's emeritus professor of
neurology at the ronald reagan ucla
medical center he joins me tonight from
los angeles and robert bartholomew he's
honorary senior lecturer in the
department of psychological medicine at
the university of auckland in new
zealand to both of you gentlemen it's
good to have you with us dr balor let me
start with you it seems the cia now
agrees that there's less to this story
than some
believe what's your take
well thank you for having me brent um
well my take is this is what we've been
saying all along uh
certainly
we expected that
this would be the final conclusion if it
is a final conclusion obviously this
report is
is
considered preliminary there's a lot of
backlash there's a lot of political
implications
but i certainly agree with what they
concluded i mean we right from the
beginning uh felt that we have to be
very
cautious and and
consider all possibilities but now we're
five years into this
and there's absolutely no evidence of
any kind of secret weapon
uh or that any foreign agent is
following our
embassy employees all over around the
world in fact every every continent now
has
has had uh some reports of of the
so-called havana syndrome
so uh
i believe do you feel vindicated dr
ballard do you and dr bartholomew do you
feel vindicated here
i think to some degree because uh we
took uh you know a lot of criticism i
mean i think one of the key things and i
and i them just emphasize this right
from the beginning
is that you know these people have real
symptoms and and you know i i have
compassion for them is i'm i'm
definitely not saying
that
that they're imagining their symptoms
that are this is not real the symptoms
are real but i think telling them they
had brain damage
is by no means uh you know
in their favor and indeed if you wanted
to pick something that would make it
unlikely that they're going to get
better it would be to
tell them that they have brain damage
dr bartholomew how does this actually
work i mean what are the dynamics behind
mass psychogenic illness or mass
hysteria
well think of mass psychogenic illness
as the placebo effect in reverse in
psychology it's known as the nocebo
effect based on negative expectations
this entire case
can be
summarized in one sentence
when you hear the sound of hoof beats in
the night
first think horses
not zebras the doctors at the state
department went for the most exotic
hypothesis early on
they went on a search for unicorns when
they should have stuck to mundane
explanations and people say things like
well the us government's been
experimenting with microwaves for years
that may be true but the us government
also experimented for 20 years trying to
develop psychic soldiers doing remote
viewing and how did that work out it
didn't work out very well just because
they're experimenting with it doesn't
mean it's true because there's something
called the laws of physics and the other
thing i'd like to point out here is that
this shifted from cuba
to other parts of the world later on
because the state department and the
department of defense issued alerts
around the world to be on the lookout
for anomalous health incidents and then
people all over the world started
reporting anomalous health incidents
because people have unusual health
incidents all the time and just because
they have a health incident doesn't mean
it's mass psychogenic illness a number
of these cases are people simply waking
up in the morning having a headache or
feeling unusual and attributing it to
this new condition havana syndrome what
dr bartholomew let me just ask you then
what what do you think prompted these
physicians when these cases were first
reported what made these physicians
think of the zebra instead of the horse
uh incompetence really and look the you
have the national academy of sciences uh
panel no one invited us to
present on that panel
you had a panel that was essentially
loaded with believers and not skeptics
this is a clear case
of politics being mixed with science and
whenever that happens the outcome is not
good i'm sure professor balo and i would
love to speak before the senate foreign
relations committee and explain more as
to what's been going on here and the
other issue here is the symptoms of
havana syndrome are so vague as to be
experienced by
any human being who's ever lived in any
week of their life headache nausea
dizziness
difficulty concentrating forgetfulness
confusion tinnitus insomnia and so when
you issue an alert around the world for
symptoms of havana syndrome and they're
so vague you are going to get uh a
deluge of people reporting similar
symptoms well let me ask dr bella about
this i mean we did see studies backing
up claims of directed energy
injuries
what do you make of them
well
they were false uh simply it was leaks
to the press initially that there were
mri abnormalities that that would be a
really
important and significant finding but
when the actual data was presented
it turns out that the mri scans of the
brain were normal there were a few
non-specific changes that we would
expect to see in any group of people of
that size and so the whole idea of mri
abnormalities was was
just bogus and then the the testing that
they reported that suggests there was
brain injury or
brain impairment where these were
non-specific tests tests for example eye
tracking and reaction time things
that
anybody with anxiety would show the same
abnormalities and they really didn't
have an actual adequate control group so
the data was flawed right from the
beginning i've got about a minute left
dr
i'll let you have this last question i
mean
how often does this phenomenon occur i
mean is this rare or is this something
that keeps popping up all the time
look there was a long history of mass
psychogenic illness and it's very much
misunderstood you know there's a problem
when pamela spratlin the former head of
the bible panel looking into this
was interviewing havana syndrome victims
and said you know i am considering the
possibility of mass psychogenic illness
and she was forced to resign because of
the public outcry and i'll leave you
with this yes a line from shakespeare a
midsummer night's dream or in the night
imagining some fear how easy is a bush
supposed a bear and in this case we're
looking at the russian bear it's all
psychology
yeah
and it's fascinating too and we are
grateful that both of you gentlemen took
the time out especially on this friday
dr bartholomew i think for you at
saturday morning to talk with us um this
is enlightening and this is an important
discussion appreciate both of you
talking with us tonight thank you
thank you